stay like this
[Music]
[Music]
do we really have to do this absolutely
it's just insane well it's mentally
irregular but it deals a deal
shouldn't we have like helmets or like
boxing hats whatever no CTE is not a
real thing that's just something liberal
people say I don't think that's accurate
why are we covered in oil uh well I have
a lot of petroleum products in my
portfolio trying to create scarcity a
little boxing ring I just don't remember
putting it on
I still don't think this is a good idea
you just had heart surgery and I'm built
like a Simpsons character I'm I'm
cleared for physical activity besides we
both need to get back in shape
this could be our new
thing it'd be it'll be the thing that we
do together back in shade I need to look
over my contract
you want to ring the bell Apollo
I was gonna ring
I was gonna ring the bell but that's
racist which we talked about but
huh you're right yeah
ding ding okay
first time
how you can lose it uh 100 Burgers I
think very strong I can't hear what
you're saying
Hunter S Biden's Freebase filled lungs
are better than yours right now oh
really well I hope you're feeling good
because I don't know if I can smell
through like some cheese yeah I like
cheese
that's the whole thing this is like my
favorite it's why I'm getting very tired
right now already
I'm I'm really getting tired if you ate
a little less cheese did a little more
oil boxing you probably wouldn't have
this problem I don't know why we are oil
boxing and why it's your thing well the
good news is after this we're gonna do
a
in a shooting competition I got it I see
uh oh my insides Burn yeah well I just I
don't know if I'm hungry or it's just
the way I've lived my life
that's my bad knee uh oh
hey yeah I do yeah you know what I can
do I'm not here I can
I'll just go to the GNC and pick up some
build bars oh because they sell them
everywhere oh yeah that's a better idea
than fighting the last one you save your
save your breath you know what I'll do
is uh I'll uh I'll have Gerald sitting
there I'll have Joe sit in the first
chair he's earned it yeah he's earned it
[Music]
.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I know
[Music]
hmm
that's the sound of Monday I mean it's
the sound of every day Monday through
Thursday at 10 A.M I'm just going to hit
it right off the top Monday through
Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern if we're not
here on YouTube and we don't tell you
that we're not going to be here you can
switch on over to rumbler mug Club
because it's Monday through Thursday 10
a.m Eastern and we have a whole hour
additional show on mug club today when
we were playing hate cymbal hate what is
it on hate symbol or speech or not hate
symbol or not okay symbol or not or not
oh no way we could do that on YouTube
now going over my back tattoos yes
we we call them Dave stamps yes
all tramped wait it took a lot in post
to get rid of that in that little intro
oh there are arrows yeah yeah I don't
know and it doesn't you know it's not
Japanese it's not Korean I don't even
know what the writing is what is it who
sued you on that I'm not sure it's a QR
code today yes it's his only it's a QR
code that it's like a Treasure Trail a
QR code to the keys to his apartment
yeah his own language of hate yes take a
break
um look today is uh one there's good
news and there's bad news but it's
mostly good news so as we are
broadcasting this right now what's going
on over there you guys you guys put your
chickens with your head is everything
okay everything good are we streaming
yeah we're streaming just about you just
about murdered some did you see this
well he almost killed that guy but
that's fine well we haven't we have a
new gentleman we're helping us with
audio today and we're just so hopefully
uh what's this what's his name there is
Casey case you're doing okay are you
doing okay there a Jose Canseco bet tell
me you didn't pay money for this name
that movie line comment below which
brings me my question of the day what
will be your first tweet when Elon
musk's purchase of Twitter is finalized
so the good news is this morning it was
announced on Bloomberg an unreliable
source of news because they were
partially wrong that Twitter accepted
the offer from Elon Musk turns out
they're still finalizing the deal but
yeah there have there has been a
tentative
acceptance of the offer yeah and that is
oh my gosh I just hope Elon Musk ties
Twitter it's going to be so much fun and
this also comes as a the EU is looking
to clamp down now on what they view as
hate speech and wanting us to be applied
internationally on social media so
they're happening at the same time and
we'll get into that a little bit because
some people will say well of course they
need to they need to moderate the
internet from you know things that are
actual crimes we've talked about this
things that are actually illegal death
threats doxing Taylor Lorenz uh but
that's not actually what's happening in
Europe I don't think it's coincidence
that this is happening at the same time
so we'll keep you updated as it's
occurring right now it is 10 22 Eastern
9 22 Central God's time
and uh we'll let you know what the stock
price is as it will we have the edit pay
working on live news as it develops so
hopefully we can uh we can break this
with you because it would be a
historical moment yes and I just love
well we'll get to a it's you've heard
the term screw you money that's a teaser
we'll get to more
uh day well first up Gerald a how are
you I am fantastic it's fantastic day
yeah we're all excited I think he's
gonna buy it and I think it's going to
be accepted they have no choice but to
accept it so yeah Freedom returns by the
way a lot of Liberals are moving to
Canada and then they realized that
Twitter's in Canada as well right it's
sort of like when people used to talk
about how uh you know they're like wow
some you know slaves escape to Canada
I'm like well it depends on when they
escape to Canada because at one point
whatever said great more slaves yeah
three yeah keep keep on look I found
this slave eh run into Mexico to the
arms of the cartel oh Jesus
you screwed both ways of Nature's kind
they'll take him in as one of their own
and you hear him you love him at Landau
Dave he's going to be uh this Saturday
in Green Bay by himself but then him and
I are in Colorado Springs June 18th you
can get tickets at lottery.com tour we
had to add a second show so a lot of
carter.com you can see Dave's dates and
there are dates together with a big fall
tour we'll be announcing Dave how are
you Ahoy good how about you good both
shows are almost sold out he didn't ask
me how I was I did well I was I'm
actually doing really well today so I
was looking forward to the question
because I would be able to say good uh
one time we'll see Hey Stephen I care
how are you I ate so much food last
night that I I weighed four pounds more
this morning than yesterday morning
really yes
wow yeah how'd you do that well I
consumed 3 800 calories in one sitting
at dinner that's not including lunch and
all the stuff I ate after dinner because
at that point I just stopped counting I
see you've read my diet book yes it's
written it's tattooed across your back
don't worry it's keto I need my decoder
ring all right so we're gonna spend most
we are going to spend most of today
discussing Elon Musk Twitter the ins and
outs and also what is happening right
now across Twitter Facebook YouTube
these International platforms that you
may not have you may not have heard this
story from the EU and what's the name of
this that because there's so many
different uh bills they propose to say
the DSA the Digital Services act which
is separate from their previous uh Bill
screw you they put forward so this is
their second attempt now to clamp down
on it more just as Elon Musk is
close to purchasing Twitter
strange we'll say it that way yeah
before that uh it's time to watch I
don't know if you know that liberals
they love to write some awful
um songs and perform them on Tick Tock
um but very few
have the balls if I may to be as honest
and informative as this one
left
[Music]
to be in your churches
[Music]
that'll stop you yeah it's you know the
left has a remarkable ability to um take
someone fetching and make them
unattractive very yes I'm just gonna say
it's like your mom's hot but I hate her
yes yeah I mean it's wrong to hate him
not hate but I hate her right hater by
the way hey control me can you put in
here I want to hit next the uh the
protester here I think we uh before we
go into Elon Musk the uh Timberwolves
Grizzlies ah can we just have lip
syncing and pretending it's a talent hey
don't you remember when Sarah Cooper did
that that was her special on Netflix was
lip syncing Donald Trump oh yeah that
was hilarious we had to sit and watch it
on Mud Club and uh laughing so mean yeah
oh yeah yeah I'm still laughing yeah
well I'm literally laughing right now
Deeds was the only way I could handle it
yes wow that was the top thing in comedy
last year yeah was it really oh Sarah
Cooper was lip sync remember she would
lip sync to Donald Trump Donald Trump
would you know be some like listen uh
you know [ __ ] hole countries and she
would just go
it's like what is it what are you you're
you're a mine you're a mine yeah you're
essentially doing what Jerry Lewis did
mugging to records yes in the 50s with a
paper mache hat yes that's why he's
still popular in France
oh yeah but see the this was better
because it was an hour of it yes she's
almost the American Michelle yes I don't
know what that means but it sounds right
there are a few French people like oh
he's uh not finally for something for me
oh that was awful I forgot that existed
yeah I uh here's the thing it's like you
know the whole idea of the right the
popping and locking is it SEC is it
sexual it's just like the it's like the
didn't look like the dance of sexuality
in nature right the mating call yeah but
not the way she did it it I mean it
looked like it was some kind of like a
chiropractic I thought she was trying to
throw up
yeah she looked like a bird
yeah like a mama bird getting ready to
feed her babies
and she had this crazy ponytail that was
like she belonged in a psych ward yes
you can't trust that ponytail that's
true it's funny every time I see Nancy
Pelosi speak when she's like getting mad
she reminds me of a bird caught in an
oil spill you know oh yeah yeah
that look yeah did she just it surely
just wants alcohol rubs on her yeah
[Laughter]
is she really yeah yes yeah heroin fine
yes alcohol not so much allegedly as
long as it's in pill form and prescribed
she's like it's fine she's the only
person who still has her hands on
Quaaludes still has her liver spotted
gross hands on Quaalude she has the last
six and he's safe
just excited every day oh man I'm
looking forward to getting to Elon Musk
but before that this is something that's
also uh just again I just want you guys
to be in a good mood today yeah this is
a celebratory movie Yes guess what if if
this happens Guess who's coming back to
Twitter well yes but guess who's also
out of a job probably Devin Nunez over
at truth social well that's fine I don't
really care because there's five million
people waiting to get on a platform that
could not have possibly predicted
technology issues right oh yeah sorry
Devin you're doing a bang-up job yeah I
know I'm not I'm not anti I'm just
saying come on yeah true socialists had
a rough rollout yeah it's been tough but
you know what they'll come back to
Twitter and they'll take over yeah yeah
it'll be a lot of merge if we're lucky
if we're lucky some members of the board
will you know just quit jump out a
window well figuratively it's a first
story window it won't be productive yeah
no exactly into a bush yes and they'll
be fine guys maybe some some Thorns yeah
maybe some thorns in a motor Bush so
it's like a story and a half yeah I mean
they can't get away with no punishment
yeah no like a hurt ankle yeah framed
right rolled yeah rolled ankle that's
exactly that's that's all figuratively
is what we're hoping for yeah so in
other good news though and this is a lot
of fun you know we all hate animal
rights activists and I don't mean people
I don't mean people who don't want you
to be cruel to animals I mean the pita
people yeah the people who believe in
total animal Liberation look into the
actual origin of PETA they don't
actually even believe that you should
have pets that was the original Mantra
of PETA really they want they want
humans and animals to live in an
entirely even playing field which would
just be the worst because you would just
X you'd have to execute all animals for
committing assault rape public urination
I mean they wouldn't last wouldn't last
the end of the week I always loved the
paid ones that would throw paint on
women yeah because it was like you see
it for a coat and it's like take that
old white lady then like a big black one
walk by in a fur coat and they're like
hi have a nice day looking sharp wow
nice looking nice yeah what is that oh
is that is that mink is that baby seal
oh I love it yeah great have a good one
yeah that's that's right or were you
gonna throw paint on my coat little
white girl yeah well you got a little
paper come on don't do a paint on me
I don't I don't wanna throw a little bit
go ahead come on let it happen
this jacket was a very expensive yeah I
didn't buy it happy it was a gift
so it's time for uh this week in protest
fails
[Music]
all right so it was game four between
the Memphis Grizzlies and the Minnesota
Timberwolves I already like where this
is going because the animal names uh yes
the NBA love it it was temporarily
interrupted uh and this is not you know
the woman usually would be the star of
the show because we want to to mock her
mercilessly but right uh the security
guard deserves some attention here we'll
go back to him but first this was a
woman dressed as a referee that's not
illegal like impersonating a police
officer I found out I looked into it
ran onto the court here you go Watch
What Happens signs
it's over there in the stands
nope Jackson
we have a
Dan ran out on that oh she just wanted
to meet her dad now here yes here's the
thing
that uh good luck
was she running out there with a 23andMe
fraternity yeah
I know it's one of yours
and she doesn't
it's a one and I don't know 28 chance I
don't know how many people have on both
teams I don't know how to add it up but
here's the thing we're gonna get to our
plan in a second which was thwarted so
that man is a hero but we want to show
you the reason it happened so quickly is
this is the security guard doing his job
watch he has a machine is it a she I
think it's a she no I looked at it it's
a security guard is she do we know 92 I
think it's someone in a ball with a
skullet Gerald I don't know can someone
you guys comment below let us know
comment below if it's a she I think
Gerald's an idiot it could be a man who
looks like a woman didn't look like a
woman at all to me well it could be a
female security guard yeah yeah that's
what I mean which could be yeah you
repeat yourself yeah so the whole point
of what I said watch the flip-flop watch
the laser beam-like beat that the
security Z has on the protester look
here we go we have it slowed down okay
here you go you see in the stands right
there there is is it a woman the
security look before she even gets up is
it a woman it is a woman it is a woman I
apologize look at this look at her boom
boom takes her out is it an African
I love cow
I'm surprised you didn't punch her I
know right but she's totally allowed to
too well look the WNBA players have to
work part-time jobs
[Music]
by the way by the way if anybody is
planning on doing this again I would not
advise it but if the person next to you
goes from this too this yeah that's a
dead giveaway the person next to her did
that like ready to record what she was
doing yeah and like quickly went up like
this and then the security guard and the
person came out I was like come on yeah
ready to record it gave it away ready to
record the ass kick you gotta be like
slow you guys should have hit a double
leg though looks like she may have had
like a Greco-Roman background because
one for an upper body clinch no leg
attacks I appreciate it but still there
could be accidental head-to-head contact
and you get accused of a headbutt like
Johnny Depp Amber Heard you don't need
that
just shoot a blast double security
guards that's what we need to see and by
the way if you want to see uh there was
almost no there was almost no gap
between like they were running together
it was like a lion chasing down against
Elvis is very similar to hats off to uh
Pop's crowd or what happened at UNT did
the same thing just carried the
protesters momentum and continued
tossing them do we have that clip
he didn't even didn't even try it
here's your momentum can I see that
again because I didn't see it happen
when it happened right next to me look
at that
nice
that's hilarious that's like this it's
like like your kid's first bike ride
just yeah yeah
you're gonna get bruised it's fine so uh
it turns out and there's stuff that
people will never see actually aired
live there's been a few people who've
kind of tussled with Paul Crowder and
then after feeling a little bit of
jostling like I don't couldn't you at
least say you're sorry and I just leave
no of course not because I know they
felt so it's like that's a big dude I
wouldn't mess with him he felt something
I didn't want so it turned out that this
lady the white lady who was tackled yeah
was an animal rights activist named
Sarah zimmel now here's the thing Sasha
Sasha Sasha I thought it was Sarah I
don't care let's call her Sarah because
I don't want to give her credit you
don't want copycats Gerald that's true
did I just doc sir
yes no you just encourage copycats
you've made her famous that's the only
thing she gets out of this is what you
just did yes because you feel good about
what you just did nobody could put Sarah
in soccer now she's in jail who's at
home feeding her 37 cats well well maybe
one of her 19 possible dads that's true
oh
sad but here's the thing she had a very
in-depth plan this just shows how
delusional left to start so let me take
you through the step-by-step plan of
this protester step one okay I believe
we have some of the uh uh yeah step one
was her plan was to run onto the court
he wears a gun holster bro
okay it's new sound guys okay not the
right one that's fine step two the guy
you just played's doing real well right
now step two was to whistle to stop the
play okay step three was to pretend to
issue a technical foul looks like an
Ocean's 11 player Ocean's eight sorry oh
there we go
ah step four then eject the Timberwolves
owner Glenn Taylor who has seated
Courtside uh all of which was thwarted
by a simple tackle but I love that this
woman thought she had five steps in her
yeah she's like all right look this is
the plan how many times we have gone and
done protests or things like that when
we've showed up you've heard me say guys
we're only gonna have a couple of
seconds at this so everyone have your
cam we have we're gonna have to stick
and move get going she's sitting there
like look to trust me I'm going to a run
onto the court then Whistle Stop the
play which people will respect because
I'm clearly the referee right look at
the outfit then I will pretend to issue
a technical foul which everyone will
respect including the announcers
obviously an official yes yeah yeah and
then I will eject the Timberwolves owner
Glenn Taylor and of course the owner of
the teamwork
I guess I have to leave nobody would
follow them yeah nobody would understand
what she's doing like it's like a
Streaker running out we're like so we
all get naked right yeah that's uh well
that makes sense yeah it'd be like uh uh
what was his name a fan man during the
Holly field uh Tyson fight I believe
that's what it was during that was it
was it Holly Phil Tyson I don't know or
Lennox Lewis something or if a fan man
came in only if only if he came in and
he was like all right go back to your
corners and like well there's nothing we
can do it's clearly the referee what did
you think would happen this idiot
couldn't get people to start the wave
let alone this
speaking of uh protest failures this is
a common theme a man known as win Bruce
celebrated Earth Day by setting himself
on fire on the steps of the Supreme
Court here we go
this part is slowed down because it was
very oh my goodness I see I just thought
it was Ghost Rider
I'd feel bad if that wasn't self-induced
yeah like those screams would be
horrifying if it weren't just a [ __ ]
Who lit himself on fire I wonder what he
thought fire would feel like yeah he's
like you know what this hurts didn't
they say not to burn snow oh I watched
that Tiananmen Square thing and it
seemed a lot obviously how useless the
Capitol Police are was he aiming a park
was that was that a fire extinguisher I
don't think it was a fire that was a
parking coach because it's aiming a
parking cone were they trying to blow on
him
it's not working wait yeah that's just a
normal parking cone what is he doing
there's got to be something coming out
of it though I thought I thought I saw
water no hey you know what I think it'll
start global warming lighting my face on
fire well here's the thing interesting
that you should bring that up Dave
because uh burning one human body if you
guys are trying to save the planet of
course Earth Day uh one human body being
burnt uh creates up to 600 pounds of CO2
I'm looking at you Hitler oh man the
real culprit of Glory Captain pollution
yeah seriously I tell you what that's
that's the worst is his lack of respect
this Hitler this was a world that we all
had to live in this has been protest
fails
[Music]
it was mostly the Holocaust what yeah
yeah no that was that was definitely the
Holocaust the killing of them it was a
component yes two things can be a lack
of respect for the environment yeah yeah
two things can be true What Hurts the
second most is a lack of respect yeah uh
I think it's time I don't know what the
official announcement is because this is
happening as we are live but I can say
this it's uh must concern musk's
concerns about Twitter May soon be uh
alleviated because they apparently this
morning and this came from Bloomberg and
New York Times uh have agreed on a deal
to settle with musk it's a good day
work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay all right went in my water you
literally get the host
I think you're doing not one of these
works I think you might be doing it
wrong
oh hold on a second give me give me give
me one give me a beat
give me a video
yeah wow
[Music]
you did try to blow into a popper so I
did too though I didn't know what it was
you know these were probably made in
China yeah was he smell that yeah they
were that is serious gunpowder oh it
really is yeah they don't play around
over there
just wanted to celebrate China for
American promotional events
preferably with large masses of people
yeah also you'd die after reading this
right just oh good it's filled with
covid okay so let me read this to you
right now and uh you let me know what's
going on if there are any updates that
I've I've missed I was just gonna give
you one update oh it was a guy Pierre
what what the security guard how can
anybody here I told you Jared was an
idiot admonishing Gerald minus Gerald
right now
no admonishes yeah none well those are
the rules we don't make them we just
call them you misgendered a hero yeah I
didn't it was very vague no he had
ponytail
but he also looked like one I mean
does he look like a [ __ ] because the
security guard the security guard look
like a [ __ ] I'm not not a biologist I
really am not I could I couldn't say I
don't know I mean it looks uh strong
like a strong [ __ ] yeah I blame I
here's the thing I understand Gerald's
you know misconception there I blame
right every girl who comes back from
those cruises with those crappy little
beads in their hair they've ruined it
for the rest of us okay fine and I only
did it once I was in Cancun well you
know when in when in drug lord City yes
they were like look you have to do this
and give us eighty dollars
so musk's uh uh he he of course made a
deal for Twitter and uh apparently this
deal is happening this is coming from
New York Times Twitter is nearing a deal
to sell itself to Elon Musk with two
people
who have knowledge of the situation uh
they said an agreement could be
announced as soon as Monday yeah that
would be today and uh it also by the way
should be noted you had some uh some
some notes on this here well it was
really interesting right so he put
together 46.5 billion dollars 46.5
billion dollars for the purchase how the
funding was actually going to break out
who was involved and it was like every
blue chip like Bank was supporting him
except the two that were advising
so he literally went to every other bank
and said hey you guys are cool you guys
over there no the guy's still advising
Twitter it's like buying stuff and then
flipping well you've heard of screw you
money this is his money literally saying
screw you yeah so awesome it's the best
way I've ever seen somebody play with
money yeah who would have thought of
that he's like you know what let's get
every Bank except the ones that are
already at Twitter it's like you don't
even need to do that I know by the way
don't you love that CNN's not talking
about it at all oh no no right now Brian
stelter is just sweating bullets oh yes
he is sweaty he's like oh my God I'm
gonna lose everything CNN said we want
to focus more on news with a new
president he's like I'm going to be
fired Mercy it and bless it now this
wait they're not going to throttle
conservatives I'm gonna lose
anything
I'll have to compete on an even playing
field oh bother seeing and plus lasted
three weeks yeah
three years generally can hold a baby
inside of her longer than this
Bruce Jenner could like pinch a baby
between her legs like a Thigh Master for
longer than that just saying three weeks
they were like that's not even giving it
a chance they're like there's no way
this is
the projections just say lots lots
literally let's pretend it never
happened yeah as soon as the discovery
people came in that they were leading
this they were like hey can you send us
the file gosh we entered into our
QuickBook software and it just started
popping up really it lasts and then said
uh-uh you forgot to say the magic word
why did Dennis and edry program our
computers this is crazy
so uh I don't know can someone give me
an update as to where Twitter Shares are
right now they jumped five percent on
the news at the time we started this
show yeah uh showing again that the
market clearly clearly is happy about
the prospect of a musk takeover and by
the way it's not like it would jump
because anyone over there on Wall Street
would have any Insider information
that's illegal you know it's uh it's up
a dollar 55 today but it's still three
ish three and a half dollars below his
bid so there's still skepticism out
there that it's actually going to happen
to some degree but it's uh I'm pretty
sure we're celebrating for the right
reasons yes yeah
some degree of skepticism you just gave
me some doubt no don't no don't be let
me have this don't doubt so here's the
thing Gerald he was in a great mood yeah
he added a Snickers bar to his bids they
took it yeah all right that's fair
that's fair he gets cranky when he's
hungry so if the deal is finalized you
can expect uh more gems like uh like
this from Elon Musk uh on uh Friday he
dropped a tweet comparing dates to the
new pregnant man emoji
and it just said in case you need to
lose a boner fast
[Laughter]
and then uh obviously expected action
from the Twitter sensors yeah uh and by
the way this was uh this is what
happened after they were sort of going
back and forth because uh leaked text
messages showed that Bill Gates
uh tried to short Tesla stock well yeah
he's holding a short position still
right Tesla stock for people who don't
know explain to people who don't
understand it well basically you're
betting that the stock is going to go
down and the more people that hold
shorts on stuff like that the the worse
it can get for you because it can just
be a spiral a big part of me feels like
that should be illegal well that's what
happened to AMC that's what the whole
the whole thing was about AMC is there
were tons of people with shorts and game
stuff and yeah GameStop is actually the
lead sorry so GameStop and then AMC as
well was kind of the next thing so
that's what they did they just bought it
and you know cost people billions yeah
equities a lot of people don't realize
that equities have created more
millionaires than anything throughout
human history more they've created more
uh really sort of members of the upper
middle class than anything that's ever
existed but if you look at the way the
stock market has been framed in and you
look at the way that big Banks obviously
uh play a role in manipulating the
never-ending bailouts that take place it
isn't the same as capitalism and that
also is something I understand the
reason for it yeah but also it's gotten
out of hand where people it's it's a
really tough pill to to swallow that
giant powerful Banks can bet on a
company failing and if enough of them
Bet On It failing it can ultimately
perhaps lead to it failing yeah
absolutely well if enough people do it
like if Carl Icahn comes out and takes a
short position on your company
everybody's following him like people
that understand his ability in this
Arena go oh he knows something yeah
we're going to do it too we're going to
sell the stock we're going to get out
here's Twitter right now
up a dollar okay
the excite I think I bought at 48
earlier yeah right before the show I was
like hey there's like five or six bucks
a share just sitting there for anybody
to take that yeah don't financially take
any advice yeah don't take any advice
this is not Jim Cramer he's gonna show
up tomorrow with a rubber mallet yeah
sell sell sell yeah
who was that Thor I don't know who is
Jim Cramer for I you know that no one on
Wall Street is actually watching him and
people at home are not watching him like
oh I'm gonna take his advice I mean
he's I'm sorry he's an [ __ ] of the
the highest he doesn't really give the
best advice either that's what I like I
think he said to sell Twitter at 30 I
don't know yeah he's like I made a
mistake tell your family goodbye yes
could have doubled your money had you
not listened to me
look you want Financial advice uh it's
very simple right you're indoors I do
work not a sponsor of the show I work
with a guy uh it's uh Matson money they
just they man it's very simple you
invest in a diversified portfolio you
reap you yield 10 you double your money
about every 10 years the stock market
wins out long term you just have to be
patient betting on stocks you know
there's the random walk Theory a monkey
with a dart board just just uh does just
as well as these experts these financial
advisors these hedge funds it is a house
of cards and anyone who comes in and
tells you they have a tip is lying the
market wins out over time you just have
to be disciplined that's why sometimes
people could you offer me some Financial
advice no I'm not going to do it nope
and I'm not going to talk about the
crypto thing because you know if you
want to make it a part of your portfolio
fine if you want to bet it all on one
specific crypto be prepared to lose your
shirt you have no idea what's going to
happen now speak yeah if you want the
best advice just watch Wolf of Wall
Street in the Matthew McConaughey speech
Jordan Belfort I found out reached out
to me well I guess he has a podcast
Jordan really no he's cool I've met
Jordan I've heard that yeah yeah you
should talk to him I should talk to him
he's actually it I mean yeah what he did
was obviously a crime and so I went to
jail yes but when you actually hear him
he know he knew what he was doing yeah
he's done his time I mean yeah he played
he played it now he it's pretty he's a
fascinating Mr Belfort just know I oh I
only just found out this last week how
to check like Instagram messages I
didn't know there were messages on
Instagram but no idea so I have a lot to
go through yeah yeah I think you'd I
think you'd like him he's an interesting
guy uh by the way speaking of companies
that I do like don't I don't think I
don't think they're an IPO so whatever
doesn't matter but uh go to build bar
that's what you saw the the oil boxing
uh built.com use a promo code crowder15
you get 15 off your next order these
things are delicious it's fantastic they
uh they have real chocolate are they
sending the ones that I asked we're
gonna we're gonna suck it some more yeah
because I I eat these so often that it's
the sponsor where I'm like you know I
need them to send me more I have them at
night I put them in the freezer they're
delicious no one needs protein bars I've
told you about this before like you know
you can get your but if you want
something that's sort of satisfies your
sweet tooth the craving uh without all
the crap it's just it's super tasty
that's why portable and easy right so
well that's not why I eat them like a
dessert sure they're portable and easy
but I mean except for other people okay
come on I ate them in the parking lot
when I don't go into the gym
I got my protein yeah yeah that's what
he marks down in his log okay built.com
Crowder 15 is a promo code uh the stuff
is delicious I like the peanut butter
fudge one it's delicious okay yeah those
are good here is something else that I
wanted to talk about okay so Elon Musk
and we'll keep you abreast as this
unfolds uh and a press release though
now uh this was April 23rd uh 2000 uh
well obviously 2022 so April 23rd was
Saturday days ago
the Council of the European Union
announced a provisional agreement for
the Digital Services act and a quote the
DSA follows the principle that what is
illegal offline must also be illegal
online now sounds good enough right no
it doesn't no so here's the problem
right away the red flag should go up
when you hear now uh Council of Europe
that's enough
that's it I don't even know if you're
just like isn't there a council of
Europe no Europe what European Union it
doesn't matter I say the words Europe
in the context of control of the
internet bat and Council yes I've
already given you all you need to know
but of course all the resources are
available at lottery.com so what is
required here and this is important you
know we've done changed my Minds about
hate speech we haven't done one in a
long time but uh it's something that
sounds good to people who aren't paying
attention if you are paying attention
you will understand that this isn't yet
another Power grab and it's a power grab
after they've already achieved sort of
an unrecognized power grab and just
recently I was again subject to this by
German law ah this happens all the time
uh so what does this mean though it
means that search engines and platforms
with over 45 million active monthly
users they'll have to monitor four and
I'll read you what's in this bill that
uh uh you know sounds good right and
then get to oh wait red flag
dissemination of illegal content people
here like well I like selling drugs or
okay or Hitman got it great okay adverse
effects on fundamental rights huh
getting a little more broad that's vague
especially when you're talking about
Europe because they don't really uh
understand what fundamental rights are
and alienable is determined by God they
don't really recognize that when you
look at their sort of the basis of
common laws I guess there uh
manipulations of democratic processes we
know what that is question election all
right for example
and then this is also included
adverse effects on gender-based violence
and minors well
why was that broad wait adverse effects
on J it's not violence against people
based on gender or violence against
minors it's adverse effects on
gender-based violence and minors that
can mean what and that's what this bill
is about that's what this proposal is
about it's about speech regarding those
issues not about actions hmm well take
out gender-based violence and and it
would make sense right
it should just say violence against
gender
violence against minors yes there you go
that's a given that would make sense we
could all be on board with it but
gender-based violence seems well adverse
effects on gender-based violence so I
thought that the gender-based violence
was an adverse effect right but yes how
do you have an adverse effect on the
violence my point if it's so we don't
want to upset the violence right yes
it's like we so numbers are high so we
would like to have positive effects yes
on gender-based violence and minors yes
yes positive effects will be given the
right of way yeah adverse effects on
gender-based violence no we're going to
keep an eye on we know you guys we know
we need you to make sure you're nice to
kids and uh nice to people that hurt
women because they're women yes yes well
the shiny rapper for this is Miners and
who wrote this it's also fraudulent
products right so they're saying these
are the things we're really trying to
protect don't pay attention it already
exists and that's the problem so let's
look at the laws a stupid sentence it's
a stupid sentence but not only that
let's look at the laws in Europe uh and
and uh hate speech this is something
I've talked with people about so many
times
and I know that we have a lot of viewers
uh obviously in in Canada in Europe um
in Australia you don't have freedom of
speech it doesn't exist it's probably
it's why I will likely never do a live
show in Europe or Australia maybe Canada
I have no idea because I could be hauled
out in cuffs they can arrest people for
speech only in the United States is it
protected and that's why again you have
to look at what would the Democrats push
for what would they have people always
oh it's not left right it's not Democrat
it's not Republican it is when the
entire platform of the DNC when the
entire platform believes for example
abortion up until including birth period
That's the platform you may not like a
lot of Republicans guilty not a huge fan
however I am precluded from supporting
the platform of Democrats on anything
because of what the platform represents
and if the platform had their way
unfettered you would have Europe
the platform of the democratic does not
believe
in freedom of speech it does not believe
in the First Amendment just as it
doesn't believe in the Second Amendment
the United States is the only place that
actually has true freedom of speech
enshrined into law
now uh let's look at Europe and their
sort of broad hate speech laws which by
the way is illegal
um uh across so like Denmark for example
it criminalizes expressing and spreading
racial hatred well we've all seen how
that can get that can get away from you
well you just committed racial hatred by
labeling that black guy a woman
accidentally it looked like a woman it's
the braids
yeah yeah well in France uh the Press
law of 1881 incitement to racial
discrimination hatred or violence these
were illegal uh and the UK uh the uh the
POA there 19 1988 section 18.
parentheses one I don't know exactly
what this means resources uh are all
available at subsection one lotto.com
criminalizes threatening abusive or
insulting words or behavior see how it
gets more and more brought insulting
words half our conversations so here's
the thing people have put in threatening
you go well of course to commit an
actual violent threat that's a crime
abusive people in their mind will go
well abusive okay physical abuse and you
see that with the Amber Heard Johnny
Depp thing where it's abusive he didn't
did he hit you he was verbally abusive
you hit him that's actual abuse yeah
or insulting words or behavior what
would insulting behavior is is that what
they mean insulting Behavior right is he
illegal in the UK is it a roast I mean
and is it a joke I mean that's the
problem is that is a joke hate speech
that's the problem is you it's all in
based on interpretation and this is the
issue is speech is you know you've heard
now silence as violence with this in the
United States they've gone one step
further ever because speech is
considered violence in Europe by the
laws speech is considered violence in
Europe if they don't like what you have
to say this has happened across Europe
for a very long time so this just
happened this weekend this is what the
40th example of me being dinged for
violating a version of some kind of this
law in Germany we have an overlay this
is where I said that there was there was
a guy will show the clip later there's a
special place I think Dante created a
circle in hell for guys like this I'll
show you the clip you'll all agree and
be guilty of hate speech too you know
David Hasselhoff in Germany that's for
sure now this was under a different act
right it was the network Enforcement Act
that already exists so that criminalizes
online dissemination of what they say
propaganda preparations against the
state treasonous forgery public
incitement disturbing public uh public P
the public piece via threats or then of
course inciting hatred against a racial
ethnic or National Group these are
the subsets of the law and again you
always think it sounds good until you
get to that last portion and guess what
they use that last portion to say what
get rid of the sitting president let me
just give you some examples right here
so the sitting President right they use
for preparations against the state wow
that's the rule they use
now you don't live in a free Society if
you live in a society that has laws and
here's the thing too by the way if you
are linked this is the problem with
globalism and this is why you're seeing
a Resurgence of nationalism that has
nothing to do with ethno nationalism
means a nation-state that you are proud
of your nation you know like Palestine
wants to be so the issue here is when
you have globalism and you link arms
with other countries
other countries that don't recognize the
right to freedom of speech you no longer
have freedom of speech so preparations
against the state okay Donald Trump gone
now internationally do they apply the
laws equally that's the standard not do
they have laws because Ayatollah is
still there yeah uh Hamas is still there
well inciting hatred against a racial
ethnic or national group I've got to
imagine you could just comb through
Hamas for I don't know a minute and find
something with the Jews yeah it's got to
be there yeah read their Charter
start there
Just For Crying Out think about it so
you get rid of the President right and
you keep actual terrorists this is the
problem that you run into it's not do
you have laws are they applied equally
and of course we know that there's
plenty of people been removed Four
Points of View and surely it's happened
sometimes on the left but very very when
people say it happens on both the left
and the right
okay let me ask you this
how many prominent liberal figures have
been suspended or are permanently
removed from Twitter the only one I can
think of was I think once it might have
been Rashida Talib or Elon Omar because
they went after Jews too hard and then
it was a temporary suspension but
something equivalent to Donald Trump
something equivalent by the way not only
on users but like the New York Post
Hunter Biden story yeah can you name it
really comment below comment below can
you think I I'm actually thinking of
this I tried to think of this this
morning none came to mind examples of
prominent liberals or liberal stories
that would have harmed conservatives
being treated that same way the kind of
story that would affect an election for
example
right any any amount what happened to
Trump as far as the president's not
being able to be on a media source to
reach the people who has never happened
right well you know what else has never
happened a President Who bypassed the
media using social media exactly yeah
they couldn't have that no that's what
happened yeah well and one other thing I
want to mention this actually doesn't
just include like we think Facebook we
think Twitter when we think of these
accounts these platforms that'll have to
manage this no no no they go a step
further they go to cloud storage and
websites which means anybody who says
anything anywhere your ability to have a
business your ability to have your files
online and not expect that the
government will be going through those
things we've got notices from platforms
recently in the last I don't know month
two months that said hey be careful by
the way if you do this this is now
something this is a private platform
this isn't open for the public we
removed from Shopify yeah we removed
from Shopify because we had the audacity
to sell a shirt yeah
oh my gosh yeah I mean it certainly
wasn't as bad as you know the actual Pro
Che Guevara shirts the guy was a
genocidal Maniac oh by the way also
wanted to kill gays and blacks read up
on Shake Avera he was like Hitler
without the selective charm and I'm not
saying that Hitler with some silver
tongued devil I'm just saying that Che
Guevara was even worse if cheever had
the resources yeah that Hitler did he
would be every bit as bad and he was
personally a sadist so you can find the
original chege of air shirts on there
it's this just it really does come down
to a lack of Education these laws can
get through when people are not paying
attention
a lot of people ask why don't you run
for why don't you ever run for office I
could run I could win we know that
depending on where I would run wouldn't
be able to do this wouldn't be able to
reach the millions of people that we
reach it all starts with people just
becoming aware I cannot tell you how
many people simply originally thought
well yeah I hate speech is bad until
they looked into it just a little bit
just a little bit if you're not paying
attention it sounds good oh okay let's
get rid of yeah violent gender-based
violence then when you understand just
like Che Guevara well Che Guevara okay
it was a revolutionary I guess of the
people just do a little bit of research
yeah called blacks insolent and lazy
stood before you I believe it was the
U.N and said of course we're going to
continue executing without trial we've
executed without trial and we'll
continue to do so and there's nothing
that you can do about it by the way Che
Guevara was also a [ __ ] was found with
a fully loaded rifle that had never been
fired in Bolivia saying I'm worth more
to you alive than dead
okay just but those shirts are allowed a
shirt mocking chica there
who executed gays as well
you you'd think they would love us
making fun of it it just requires a
little bit of Education I've got a
silver lining for you talked about hate
speech and we always say We'll Define
hate speech well guess what this
actually has trusted flaggers as well so
they are going to have people out there
that they trust to go out and flag this
harmful content hey by the way let's put
this in context remember Jen sackey was
asked about the Joe Rogan thing yeah and
a lot of people try and say oh this is
just you know these are these extreme
wings of the party are creating uh
they're creating an issue out of this
when it's not you know hey maybe guys in
the control room get that uh that
podcast where jensaki was talking about
kids uh gender uh she only a couple
months ago
said right well we're really glad to see
what Spotify is doing we would like to
see more authoritative sources and more
fact Checkers so keep in mind that's
right that's the White House Press
correspondent okay she's out there
calling social media
to do what Spotify is doing so when
people say it's a private company is it
really a private company though when
it's wink wink Spotify wink wink we
really hope that you do the bidding that
we want you to do wink wink right this
is someone who has the ability and has
the year of the president of the United
States everyone in that Administration
by President I mean Kamala Harris and
former Vice President Joe Biden the
United States can affect real change and
then only recently started crying on a
podcast because my God some parents
aren't letting their children transition
at six or seven years old yeah this is
no longer a fringe issue the same people
who say your children have the right to
transition are the same people who say
Spotify
get rid of more Rogan hey everybody else
take a page from Spotify by the way
these International bills these are from
places that we support as liberals here
in the United States because we're
globalists we want to be more like
Europe I think we're better than Europe
that's why we left I don't want to be
anything like Europe no well the
government has officially become the mob
hey Spotify sure would be a shame if you
lost that pretty company of yours that's
exactly what it is it's the same [ __ ]
yeah yeah it is but what point do you
say it's no longer Fringe it does
disease of what happens with the left as
you say hey wait a second hey wait a
second this is this is wrong and they
said this isn't happening remember you
say hold on a second it seems like
you're sexualizing children that's not
happening that's a that's a straw man
you're just trying to scare people and
then it goes well this is well it's only
a very small select few no one even
cares about enamel and then they end up
saying well it's happening and what so
how does it affect you and then it ends
up being if you don't support it you're
a bigot so we start with it's not
happening gaslighting and then well it's
just a small percentage of people and
then finally we end up with if you don't
support the bill in Florida that
prevents sex being taught to Kids
kindergarten through 12. and you know
what let me just answer this because
this is something that by the way could
be banned in the UK in Europe just to be
clear into this bill the kind of don't
say what they refer to as don't say gay
bill in Florida which was don't offer
hyper-sexualized curriculum to Children
K through uh three that's the kind of
thing the kind of speech that Governor
DeSantis and the majority of Floridians
support and believe could be banned
under these new international agreements
and acts and these are agreements that
the current Democratic party supports it
is no longer a fringe issue
I just hope that people are aware of
this when they always try and say oh the
trans saying who that affects like two
percent no no it doesn't affect two
percent it affects everybody when
there's compelled speech yeah and if you
think it's not coming it is coming given
do you have an update for us well of
course I found the psyche video oh okay
okay well I'm just saying of course it
affects you one it affects 100 because
if you don't say the right thing you can
lose your job your livelihood everything
that you've worked for based on the fact
that you go I don't think you should be
able to mutilate a child right right
sorry that that's I don't understand why
that's another extreme opinion right
well this is what happened we can show
you the sequence on our show you can go
back to 2014 2015. we had transgender
individuals on the show who said of
course I'm never talking about
transitioning children that's child
abuse these were transgenders who were
on the show by the way we had one argue
what's a lesbian
on the show there was a lesbian and a
transgender arguing about this in the
lgbtq AIP I think in 2015 transgender
saying this is of course you're just
this is a fallacy no one is talking
about children that's child abuse these
same people now are saying how can you
not allow your child to transition
you're a bigot and this is reflected by
the people in the highest offices in the
land now that we have it here you go
here's Jen sackey getting teary-eyed
about the idea of children not making
decisions that could affect their sex
life forever wedge issue and an attempt
to win a culture war and they're doing
that in a way that is Harsh and cruel uh
to a community of kids especially I'm
I'm like going to get them I'm going to
get emotional about those issues because
it's just it's horrible but uh it's
unbelievable you know it's it's like
kids who are bullied
this is like all these leaders are
taking steps to hurt them and hurt their
lives and hurt their families and you
look at some of these laws in these
states and it is going after parents who
are in loving relationships who have
kids it's completely outrageous
um but it is it is a wedge issue sorry
and this is an issue that makes me
completely crazy
um but yes it's the issue that
um it's not a reflection of where the
country is it is absolutely a reflection
of how disconnected you are from the
country let me give you an example right
now I'm going to say something that
under this new act would probably be
illegal in Europe Germany have your band
button ready by the way you don't get to
say in anything because you're
responsible for how many world wars now
yeah uh all of them yeah don't care oops
you know you're talking about 60 70.
it's not all that long in the realm of
human history we're still keeping our
eye on you I will say this when they say
well look there's a curriculum ban
people from discussing heterosexual
marriage with children
no it also doesn't ban discussing your
personal relationships it's just
inappropriate however I would argue uh
yeah it's more appropriate to discuss
heterosexual relationships with children
than same-sex relationships and marriage
why because it doesn't require much of
an explanation is this an argument that
you really want to make the vast
majority of relationships since the
beginning of time have been heterosexual
relationships that is I dare say normal
meaning the norm meaning it is the most
likely to occur it's not that hard to
explain to a child Boy Meets Girl boy
falls in love with girl boy and girl get
married have babies then if you want to
get into the 1.5 percent who are two
dudes look it's more confusing because
there's more explanation for the same
reason you probably wouldn't teach kids
about child rights or arranged marriages
and by the way I'm not saying that
arranged marriages are necessarily
morally wrong I don't like them but my
point is of course you wouldn't need
people act as though there's an
equivalency there's not when when
something is far outside
the realm of average
it requires more explaining why because
the vast majority of kids there
understand that men and women go
together and can make babies so it's not
as big of a deal to say my wife for a
man or my husband for a woman as it is
for a man to say my husband because most
kids are going to go what was that well
it's the same as when you get into
middle you don't cover every single
fetish and every single thing that
happens either it's like you're young
you don't understand it fine if parents
want to explain that to a kid that's
fine too like I don't really care but
it's like yeah you're not in middle
school going like all right now this is
uh this is bondage this guy he's
powerful in his day job but he likes to
be humiliated she Stomps on him with
these heels yes like it's not like that
you know that was taught to me in high
school but in the janitor closet well
yes I would did you know Willie yep
he is doing a long sentence Oh yeah I
believe it's three life terms which is
odd because he didn't kill anything no
that's their Spirit yeah yeah but yeah
it's it's if you if look if honestly
like if my son asked me what she never
has like do people have two moms I'm
just gonna be like yes I'm due and I'm
just gonna leave it at that yeah and
that's just my own personal opinion and
that's it and you know that's fine but
it's like but you've made a good point
to me a little while ago which was I
didn't know my teacher's uh first name
yeah I didn't I didn't know who my team
teachers were married to I didn't know
any of that stuff in in elementary
school I don't think it's necessary I'm
not saying that they can find out they
can't say anything but it's like I don't
see what that has to do with the
curriculum I once saw one of my first or
second grade teachers at by the way
Canadians you can comment below Harvey's
I don't know if it still exists in
Canada it was like a burger franchise
not very good and uh I once saw I
believe her name was made in
yep I was I had her kindergarten in the
second grade and uh I I saw it hobbies
and I was like oh look it's you know
it's like seeing an animal in its
natural habitat I was like okay Madonna
and she you know what she did she did
she was she would
this is it this is not where we interact
yeah and that's okay Coney Island when I
was a kid same thing I saw my teacher
and I I didn't understand it I was like
what like I thought she just goes into
the closet until we come back the next
day I was so confused just go into a
cocoon yeah the problem Dave well no but
a lot of them are coming out of the
closet in the classroom but that's the
thing is like that you never you see
them in their natural habitat that's
weird that is not the purview of a
school to teach my child about sex at
age five and my point is everything that
we just said which is a response to what
teachers are already doing
is considered hate speech to the left
you just saw it with jensaki that's the
issue if someone who has control of your
children for eight hours a day wants to
indoctrinate them in a way which is very
very new to keep in mind there have been
gay people since the beginning of time
but trying to shove the lgbtq on all
children and black lives matter and by
the way we also have some interesting
polling data we'll talk about this
tomorrow that Gen X is the least racist
and now Zoomers Generation Z are the
most racist since the oldest generation
so let's skip the few generations and
now racism is alive again told you you
can go back to 2015 where I was saying I
think you're going to see more racist
than ever in my lifetime because this is
a divide and conquer from the left but
what can happen is they can indoctrinate
your kids with lgbtqaaip they can
adoption your kids with black lives
matter and white privilege and these
these these white guilt tests and your
response is labeled hate speech just
like you can go and create new laws that
are in violation of your St of your
state constitution Pennsylvania you can
create Mass mail-in voting which by the
way ironically isn't allowed in most of
Europe but here in the United States
completely unprecedented that can be
made into policy and then if you come
out and speak against it even if you're
the sitting president you are removed
this is what this is how you you silence
the response that's what's insane it's
like having two lawyers in a court and
no one has the ability to cross-examine
and they are moving because they don't
like what's happening with the Elon
musks of the world they don't like
what's happening with Rumble like I said
if all of you left YouTube and went to
rumble nothing would make me happier you
can go watch us on Rumble right now live
but many of you don't you're still here
on YouTube because they have a ton of
resources so let me give you some more
examples of hate speech and then we'll
get to STI awareness month so in the UK
a guy was jailed and charged with hate
speech for singing Kung Fu Fighting
which rendition which one
I don't care or you know I mean he was
really bad at singing yeah really bad
everybody's a Critic Dave they should do
that in Detroit for everyone who
karaoke's Journey oh born and raised in
South Detroit just grab him no no stop
it stop it Journey's not even from
Detroit so why is this your Anthem and
by the way no Seeger on the list not
allowed no no uh but not out of your
mouth not in Detroit recent trial in
Finland attempted to convict a a Finnish
MP and a bishop of hate speech for
quoting the Bible what
quoting the Bible so I'm just giving you
some examples and you can we have so
more uh so many more did they think
they're going to use yeah
like this bishop was there and he was
speaking to the guy's like all right
where's this going a Bible there's a
Twist what he's not reading Harry Potter
up there I'm confused but I would also
arrest him for Harry Potter because that
JK Rowling's a Turf yes I hear I learned
this term last week also but now I live
by it and by the way speaking of it I
stand by my statement that there's a
special place in hell
for this guy Germany so let's go into
what pocd actually is this is a subset
of OCD this is where somebody with OCD
may have unwanted harmful or sexual
thoughts about children this often
results in panic anxiety distress even
depression people living with pocd have
no intentions of harming a child yet
they are tormented with the thoughts of
possibly doing so oh you know what that
wall would look nice with
figuratively figuratively yeah
figuratively figuratively figuratively
yeah uh well look and by the way smash
the like button if you can't stand that
guy they're just tormented this is what
happens right there why would you allow
sorry ah yeah they're tormented is
what's going on the poor guys tormented
they're tormented with thoughts that
they don't want to act hey how about
this I don't care
I don't care yeah oh you have a thought
about the sexual talk about children bye
you come back bullet
yeah I don't I'm sorry your brain
doesn't work for a society oh I'm sorry
you were sexually abused don't care yeah
he said oh they don't they have no
desire to actually do anything with
children yeah they typically don't until
they do right until they do I can't
trust that they will not they will stay
in that I don't ever want to act on this
category right they're going to it
doesn't matter doesn't matter if you
look at the rehabilitation rate it's
very low let me ask you this let me ask
you and let me ask you this if not
people who are sexually attracted to
children
it are there any issues for that man for
what will be the mainstream Democratic
platform just so you know within five
years guarantee it come back here we're
2022. just like I referenced 2014 2015
Market
it will be the mainstream platform not
saying it'll be the mainstream platform
that they encourage pedophilia right but
they will encourage an approach of
Rehabilitation
if not
pedophiles who are actively having
sexual thoughts about children
what issue is it for you where no
explanation it requires an action
which one to me that's it to me that's
one of those it's a oh okay you're
having sexual thoughts about children
don't care why you have to leave now
I don't go figure it out in the
wilderness yes you're not allowed around
children ever no no you cannot even go
home and get a carry-on
you're out
if not the issue of sexual attraction
admittedly right two children
is there any issue that you're willing
to make a decision with finality on
without going let's not everything
requires understanding that perspective
and the thing is the left loves to apply
this retroactively like well Hitler uh
we'll never let that happen again really
because Hitler didn't run by the way on
Exterminating the Jews that wouldn't
have been like the party of Jew
extermination it ended up being shoehorn
in through the kind of identity politics
it's very similar to what you see
happening with the left today right uses
he used diseases he blamed him economic
woes Health the point is he didn't so
it's easier for you to look back and say
oh that was terrible well you're able to
look back and issue a judgment but what
about here today when it's happening now
if not sexually attracted to Children
what issue do you say that's a red line
because this guy doesn't have it there
no that's my everyone should have it
somewhere at some point okay
we'd also be remiss and by the way you
guys can update me uh is there anything
there's nothing on Elon no we're still
waiting okay they're not even talking
about it uh on uh on uh is that tubing
it is
okay he's talking about we live in a
society where's that guy this is why no
one trusts the media oh you're trying to
sell we need to create a bill so you
don't so mistrust in our institutions
yeah you know what no amount of memes or
even fake news that I could present
online could so more mistrust than that
guy spanking it on a zoom call and still
having a job with the most trusted name
in news Well he said he couldn't get
through a zoom call and wear pants no
well he wanted his own he couldn't use a
sticky note to show called
that's what brought the network down
laughs for crying seriously this guy's
on CNN right now still there he's on CNN
and they blame us it's our fault for
sowing mistrust it's the same thing
won't you have former Vice President
Biden receiving more votes than anyone
in the history of ever and I was like
what you don't believe that I don't want
to be accused of sowing mistress but not
really
no I just I masturbate on work calls
what what you're not a legal
correspondent well you should just shut
up and work harder okay I hate speech
it's the sound of one hand slapping now
we'd be remiss if we uh because we want
to do our part if we let April pass Us
by without acknowledging uh STD
awareness month isn't STI awareness
month I thought it was STI now
that's what I've heard but didn't I
don't know what the difference I thought
I thought uh is it always I thought it
was different STD and then St so a
disease versus an infection every time I
would go to the doctor it'd be like STD
why do you keep coming in oh right wear
a condom so they never told you STI no
they were always like STD so I thought
it was but now they're saying they're
burning they're interchangeable why are
they changing it I really don't know I
was looking in maybe is it getting worse
well what I thought was you know for
example if you have a cold or something
and you go in and they'll say well it's
bacterial and they'll give an antibiotic
or it's viral and they don't I thought
an STI like infection was maybe
bacterial versus the disease State
because the virus is you can get a
treatment right or you know the best
cereal turns out they are completely
interchangeable they're just they've
changed it to STI to destigmatize it
yeah because you don't because sexually
transmitted is the good part yes it's
the disease and the uh infection that we
want to make sure we don't want to and I
don't know that infection is any more
palatable it's not
from what I understand neither is very
palatable they both end up with a sore
throat
[Music]
because we're now going to change it to
sexually transmitted pustule yes
[Laughter]
it's actually transmitted pustule we
don't want to stigmatize it no no what
if you think about STDs you're a dirty
boy yes here's your antibiotic yes now
I've I've been very lucky I I can't
imagine I know people who haven't though
2020 alone CDC reported 2.4 million new
that's when they used to say STD it's
like Isis and isil
that is a lot of people 2.6 million wear
a scum you dirty dirty people so look we
do want to uh help inform you and we're
going to go to mug Club here in a little
bit uh so here to educate us on uh STD
uh awareness month and to educate
everyone out there who may not know is
uh herpo the STI uh the STI clown hi
herpo thanks for being here sir hi kids
I'm herpo the STI riddled clown and
let's just by the way be sure to clean
the mic up after so um so you're here to
share with us some some STI facts
correct I have a ton of venereal
diseases and that makes herbo a sad
clown so like a sad Jerry like a sad
Jerry Lewis clown it up at a uh
concentration yeah no more like a hurts
when I bathroom sad and I have lip sores
on my mouth which technically makes it a
felony for me to blow balloon animals
and hand them to Children yeah that
would be felony battery a wonderful uh
and that's I don't know what is that you
have there oh don't
jeez I thought it was glad we get some
use out of it wonderful so um yeah
hornies so you're here to share the fact
about STI prevention that's primarily
fact number one the best way to prevent
an STI aside from abstinence right
Gerald wow is with a prophylactic as
herbo always says don't be account dumb
and wear a scumbag but then that didn't
rhyme even but okay that's slogony at
all number two genital acne may not
irritate a case of SDI and maybe a
simple case of genital pimples oh my God
that's disgusting yeah what kind of
person has genital acne well I do what
oh my gosh what oh Finnegan I didn't
even know you were here oh geez why why
is he here again I'm Ronald's ride
that's his name when he's not her PO
dude I told you not to use my real name
your name's Ronald like McDonald's you
shut your mouth that's like the n-word
do we clowns yeah oh yeah yeah because
who could forget 100 years hundreds of
years of clown slavery yeah we'll have a
word out of you and I'll spit in your
mouth yeah go ahead I probably got half
of what you got okay enough all right
you are both just
absolute animals thank you the two of
you continue with your facts number
three child rape is an epidemic in
Africa largely due to the entrenched
belief that sex with a virgin can cure
sexually transmitted diseases such as no
that's enough I've heard I've heard
enough you know Finnegan get get your
Ronald get your ride out of here this is
enough I don't want him in here get him
Finnegan come on hurry up get him out of
here that's enough that's enough purple
all right look uh oh my God hey it's
getting real oh boy oh
down here okay yeah no one's floating uh
except for this break YouTube I wouldn't
I wouldn't blame you for Banning us for
that spectacle uh we're gonna go play
hate symbol or not YouTube piss off
[Music]